[Music]
my name is Kamran Wafaa I'm a
theoretical physicist working on string
theory which is an area trying to
connect ideas from quantum gravity all
the way to particles and how the
universe works at the beginning now the
future on the smallest to the largest
why do you think ideas are still
important today in every area there are
details and they're big pictures and the
people who shape up them I shape up any
given field are they want to contribute
to the big ideas the big ideas are not
necessarily technical but they give you
a mission for that field and so those
ideas are typically not something very
difficult to appreciate by bigger
communities so these big big pictures or
big ideas are something that can be
shared from outside with outside the
community as well
a few many ideas in string theory which
are deep are precisely of that type that
cannon in my opinion should be shared
with the broader public
string theory is trying to explain what
we are made of how the universe works at
the most fundamental level what are the
basic ingredients whether the forces
between particles how did the universe
come to be what does it black forward
what is the future of the universe or
for us all the deep questions that
everybody wants to know it's kind of
like yeah of course I want to know that
does this feel a thing
do you say about them and indeed string
theory has begin has begun to offer a
song some context into terms of which we
can begin to answer these deep questions
for example we have learned that the the
matter in the universe is all unified
into one that unity is quite amazing and
that's what's one of the elegant things
each other once sounds philosophical at
the same time is unifying crystal
explaining all of physics so while one
must might think that all this sounds
like very just wishful thinking about
aesthetic this has come out to be real
in the context of string can be realized
so so they're fortunate to be having
such a structure where potentially
explains everything around us in terms
of this unifying picture there
how the matter all comes together how
the forces get unified and how that
comes to describe the geometry of space
and time
others Einsteins clearly fit with
quantum mechanics out of the black holes
come to the picture of the big bang work
what's gonna happen in the future all
them together from the smallest to the
biggest
well how the forces work too hard
everything microscopically behaves so
that sounds like a very big theory then
yes where has your work taking you
within that so my work actually has been
has been related to different aspects of
this field I have been interested in
mathematical and geometrical on their
paintings of this subject how the string
theory work we have learned that in the
context of string theory the dimension
of the space-time is not just three
Slayer on one temporal direction but
also it has extra dimensions next your
dimensions are new in physics and what
do they have to offer what why don't we
see these extra dimensions around us
well because they are tiny and if they
are tiny it's hard to see them in the
experiments but even though they are
tiny carries us what sheet they have and
what how many holes they have or exactly
those details turn out to impact the
things we see around us like how many
particles we have what are the forces
what are the masses of particles and all
these gets related to these tiny
geometries that we don't see so
translating geometry to observable
things around us forces the particles is
is what is one of the areas I have been
most interested in in this subject and
so does this apply specifically to this
universe or does it have ramifications
for other possible universes so the
theory the string theory is an
all-encompassing theory which in
principle does not limit us to the
observed universe
it basically studies all possible
consistent would-be universes ours of
course being one of them but it's not
limited to that one so yes indeed we
hope and we envision the string theory
is a theory of all possible universes
what we call the string theory landscape
the landscape of all possible universes
is what we aim to understand what are
they what are the ingredients in all
these universes
what is what is what is universal among
them all these different universes what
features do they have in common
what is different between them what what
picks out what we are in is that
something special about our universe or
is it just one of the random ones so
these are precisely the kind of
questions we're interested in answering
this and so is this way your swamp one
term comes in - in relation to the
landscape yes so they're one of the
areas I have been working on is called
the swampland the spring landscape so
the landscape you know it's the kind of
universes that we can obtain in string
theory by choosing some particular small
space that I told you are invisible
depending on which choices you have you
get this set of things that are you can
observe which we call landscape but if
you did not know where they come from
you could have imagined there would be
universes not look superficially okay
but you try to find you know spaces
which give you those yours as you find
you cannot get them so something that
you think may have exist that don't
exist so those we call they belong to
swampland that is there would be
universes that look fine but they just
don't exist for example gravitational
force is among the all the forces that
we know of
we know for forces gravity turns out to
be the weakest of all you could have
contemplated universes in which gravity
is not the weakest force but our
universe is not like that it turns out
no universe you can obtain with gravity
is not being the weakest force so the
gravity being the weakest force is true
for all the would be universal in terms
of and all the other ones for which the
gravity is not the weakest force belong
to the swamp let me say so you could
have imagined such a universe which just
process cannot be consistent that's
that's an example of it and there are
many such things that we have learned to
be the case I'm you're basically
exploring what distinguishes a good
possible theory of possible universe
with the universe that just cannot exist
even though they look fine and you know
how do you go about exploring this sort
of terrain is it abstract theoretical or
is it evidence that would help your
theory it is in large portion its
abstract and theoretical but there are
occasionally and what I mean by that is
that
we look at string theory and we look at
what are these different universes you
get from these different small spaces I
study them and we try to change them and
see what kind of patterns we see
so that's abstract and theoretical on
the other hand the consequences are
concrete that in our universe for
example we say gravity is the weakest
force but we can't see if it's true in
our universe and it is so indeed the
features that we say are universal
better apply to our universe always
we're missing them or it better be that
our universe is wrong the good
landscapes it cannot be that our
universe is a swampland so that's the
test so therefore any criteria we come
up with better be that our universe is
not violating that condition to be in
the landscape rather than being in the
swamp so what kind of significant comes
all consequences to string theory leaves
why should we care about strong in
string theory today well it is the
reason we care about string theory is
that we believe I spy and have the
correct description of gravity which is
a geometric picture of how gravity works
by the curvature of space and time on
the other hand we also know at the
microscopic level the tiniest level
quantum mechanics is important or the
atoms work since we know quantum
mechanics is a fact of life in the real
in there in the real world in the
microscopic regime and Einstein's theory
seems to be correct in a macroscopic
description of gravitational forces well
if you take Einstein's theory I take it
to the extreme of small and small
they're shorter and shorter microscopic
the descriptions of it you better have a
consistent theory with quantum mechanics
and there is no other framework today
which is consistent with Einstein's
theory at quantum mechanics at the same
time string theory is the only candidate
we have which combines Einstein's theory
with quantum mechanics in a consistent
framework and how is it that it brings
about that gap between Einsteins arian
constant it is actually one of the
miracles we don't understand how it does
it what we found is that if you study
these vibrating strings which are these
excitations that we have one of them
modes one of the little modes that we
string happen which is very tiny strings
turns out to have exactly the same
properties as a as mediating
gravitational force that is the exchange
of this little thing between other
particles melius gravitational force
why had to have this property is not
clear but it turned out that this this
theory just does it and so many things
in strictly we don't understand why it
works and it's really magical and part
of the reason we believe in it is that
nobody put it in my hand
it's not like somebody says you know
what I'm bored I want to put this thing
in so let me just change my theory so
that's gravitated know people studies
started studying Street here and they
say oh there's gravity in this I didn't
put it in where did that come from so it
gives more credence to the theory it's
kind of brings up things we want to have
without actually putting it in so we
believe that's one of the beautiful
aspects of strength in this magical
property that things that you get out of
it are more than what you put there and
what would opponents to string theory
what are the biggest problems with this
area so the opponents would rightly
point out that it has been zero
experiment or verification of string
theory string theory is part of science
and all science should be vetted by
experiment know that so why haven't we
had experimental verification of string
theory well part of the issue is the
size of the strings
my theory is 10 to the minus 30
centimeters are smaller and just to give
you a scale that's ten to the twenty two
orders of magnitude smaller than the
size of the atoms so you put ten to the
twenty two strings next to each other 10
to the 22 that's billions of billions of
billions next to each other roughly
something of that work there's a huge
number just to get one animal so it's
very difficult he zoom in that smaller
space you see that strength so therefore
naturally you're gonna have difficulty
measuring experimentally verifiable
aspects of it of course we're trying to
nevertheless try to deduce some
experimental aspects of string theory
which could be observe observe than me
and your irrefutable sign of string
theory it's going to be very difficult
and we have some ideas and in particular
in the context of cosmology we're coming
up with a few ideas for example that's
one of the areas that I have for example
and if you're my course I've been very
interested in recently trying to
understand the nature of the dark energy
what is the dark energy maybe we also
have dark matter so most of the universe
in terms of energy
95% of
is the form of dark energy and dark
matter combined and are you are our
visible universe are matter it's just 5%
of the whole of the universe energy so
what is this 95% made oh well strength
theory seems to have offers new ideas
about what this is and how they interact
what is the relation between dark energy
and dark matter so so one of the one of
the prevailing views up to now has been
that the dark energy the energy that
pair meets all the universe is constant
that doesn't change with time recent
ideas that I have worked on with my
colleagues as of a year ago so just that
the energy of the universe may actually
be changing over time and if the energy
of the universe is going down for
example you see that the acceleration of
the universe would change and and the
ideas that the taxation on the universe
in the recent past has been changing and
therefore by detecting how this how they
like you get from supernovae and other
other Astrophysical objects you can
detect the rate of expansion or whether
it's slowing down or not and based on
that you can find with the dark energies
depleting or not so there will be new
signs of connecting string theory to
observe universes so there could be
different ways we could potentially be
successful in getting extra methyl
consequences out of string theory and so
what new explanations do you have for
what dark energy and dark matter is in
the relationship between them so what we
are finding is that the dark energy is
is if you think about the energy usually
but usually when we find a constant
energy we're at the minimum of some some
energy configuration like if you are at
if you have a ball if you are the bottom
of the ball if you put the pebble at the
bottom of the ball or something doesn't
roll it just stays there that's minimum
of that energy so just take that analogy
of the bowl so what we have learned is
that our universe may not be like your
book might be like slope and you put a
pebble it starts rolling so that's the
picture and the energy is just basically
the height of that pebble above the
table so as as the pebble begins to roll
down the energy is decreasing so that
model about how our energy is decreasing
with this simple model of this rolling
and what is the relation between the
slope of this slope how how much is it
tilted compared to its height these
ideas are coming from string theory
you're trying to give you a picture of
how fast is depleting and so where we
are pursuing these ideas on
to see whether we can connect with
observations and is it so it's the
biggest drawback in your experiments
just we don't have the technology to be
able to observe these sort of things
this one we can so in other words most
of them what's the string theory does is
going to be very difficult if you want
to observe a string itself it's gonna be
very difficult because it's so small but
there are some aspects of string theory
that you can observe for example gravity
is the weakest force that you can see
without going to a microscopic
description if you put two electrons the
gravitational attraction is much smaller
than their electric repulsion at the
same distance it's just very weak
gravity so that's the universe that we
live in and that's something consequence
of string theory but that's not strong
enough to say this proof string theory
you want to have more definitive
predictions of strength day other than
just this fact so there are other things
like dark energy depletion potentially
that we can potentially observe in the
next five years or so these could be
measured in principle trying to get to
the core of string in terms of can I see
an actual string with its you know that
size object well that's gonna be many
many centuries in the future probably
because that requires a huge amount of
energy but you know we might have gotten
lucky because early universe you're the
huge amount of energy that Big Bang had
a big amount of energy so you could have
produces huge gigantic energetic strings
and maybe purchased we can understand
enough about string theory that the
signature of this big imprint is
somewhere in the sky now magnified
because the universe expanded and in
fact so rapidly perhaps we can see some
signatures of these tiny strings in some
form in the observed universe and in
particular in the background microwave
radiation that astrophysics have been
detecting so so there is hope there is
hope we're still not there and the
criticism of saying string theory has
not yet connected with experiments is it
it's a valid prism and so in terms of
advancements for your own work what
would be a goal that you're aiming for
or something that you'd love to see in
the next 10 years or you're really
hoping for that would be observe a
breakthrough in I think understanding
this property of dark energy in
particular and the relation
Dark Matter is something that i'm i'm
particularly interested and
understanding their relationship between
that stream theory both theoretically
why it's working the way it does
can we deeply understand why it's
interacting the way it does restraint
there do we know enough about string
theory to discuss it this way as well as
whether we can actually observe it in
our universe these would be fantastic if
we can actually see some predictions in
the general way from string theory in
our class to observe universe and
luckily luckily the experience that are
being done now are exactly in the same
scope as five ten years from now and
where we would know some of these
answers we may get lucky
who knows i'm hopefully we get lucky and
do you have a sort of call to action for
other string theorists is there like
specific area you think you should be
placing a focus where other string
theorists may be armed i think that
string theorists by and large are a very
very diverse group of people they're
very talented they're brilliant people
are very dedicated people so i'm not in
a position to say what everybody should
do I'm like one of them but I would hope
I would hope that a number of us work
harder in trying to connect string
theory to real world this is the most
difficult challenge for string theory
and probably I think many of my
colleagues have kind of thought that
that's perhaps too challenging and try
to do something a bit more practical and
with their research but I think even
though it's tough I think we should try
push that direction more and that's my
view and that's what I have been working
on most of my time in the past that's
obviously ten years or so more than ever
to try to understand in what way can be
fine evidences of our universe from with
your string theory and do you feel that
is any sort of like philosophical
underpinning to what you're doing or
don't be anything like philosophical
ramifications in your work in trying to
describe the world in this way yes this
is a very good question science and
scientists used to be much more
philosophical accentuated
for reasons that I don't need to
understand many of my colleagues don't
want to be related to philosophical
thinking and to me as a surprise III
think that in a sense all scientists are
perhaps amateur philosophers of the
first string that is they might not have
you know education or
or training in philosophy but a lot of
what they're doing is what philosophy
the way they look at things is actually
a philosophical like the aesthetics
aspects of their subject how they look
at what it should be this is not science
this is philosophy so whether they
accept it or not philosophy is a big
part of science it's a big part of
scientific methodology and I think I
don't think there's anything to be seen
to be shying away from the subject I
think philosophy is is is their way to
collect that bigger picture is science
and we always have it in science we did
he talked about it but for some reason
it's not it is it is not involved it's
not in fashion to say you know we have
talked about philosophical discussions I
mean a lot of it is in some sense
aesthetic is unification of particles
it's why should they be unified because
I like it no because you think about
something that's the right thing to
happen but why there's no scientific
basis it may have may not have been like
this but we like it
why or if you have another example if
you I'll give you something that's been
very useful for me
so but you know if it's such a structure
let me call it structure a and you know
a structured let me call it structure B
and suppose you know there's some
relation between structure and
structurally so you know a has some
resemblances in many aspects structure
be your observers and then you discover
a cousin of a let me call it a prime
well so what you say well there's a
cousin this immediately raises the
question what is the cousin of B prime
there must be some you look for it
why it's a fossil fuel point there's
nothing scientific there it's just the
parallelism is so forth so that kind of
thinking which we do a lot in science
without saying it it's horrible I would
say that a lot of our methodology
without actually formally think that we
is toss off it and I like it I have no I
don't shy away from floss is that a
particularly scientist or philosopher
who has really influenced you either
when you're younger or inspires you now
I think I get influenced by also all
great scientists
I mean you start all the way from Greek
philosophers whose stomach scientists
the old Persian scientist all the way
to Galileo New Times you know you name
it you go on
Einstein fine men and more mother I
think science that beautiful beauty of
science is that every mind thinking
about it at something as long as they
think deeply about them we have many
examples in the past and even present I
mean my own adviser is one of these
amazing Giants in physics so I always
get inspiration from all these ideas but
the inspiration is actually part of the
thing that the whole community develops
further after you get them you know it's
not to say that anyone is not wrong
brilliant minds Einstein was wrong
Newton was wrong
Galilei was everybody's wrong at some
level so we're not we're not trying to
use agile you know we're not trying to
make a hero out of scientists that's not
my view I think what I what I hope to
learn from scientists is the scientific
thinking and understanding what they
added how a new viewpoint came about not
to say that this scientists for some B's
is infallible or it's beyond everybody
else no they're just like everybody else
maybe they thought more deeply about
something maybe they spent a lot more
time and yes we are lucky to take their
insights and develop it further in some
sense in my view science is always work
in progress none of this in my opinion
none of the things we know about science
today are really absolutely correct
although assumptions are possible I
don't believe any of that believe any of
the principles of physics are exactly
right of course they are more right than
they were 100 years ago so the things we
know today I trust much more than we did
let's say 50 years ago 100 years ago but
that's not to say okay we're done we
understood it finished let's move on no
science is always a work in progress so
super interesting so do you think that
we never we just move nearer to fact or
truth that we never sort of reach it
that's that's the way it has been so far
and I do see changing in the fastest in
the foreseeable future and finally would
you be able to say you were describing
string theory to a child also one really
young how would you describe it it's no
simple from
well and this the description would be
what is everything made of are they made
of like particles or little spaghetti
loops on my child uses spaghetti and
algebra what are what are things made of
and how do they touch hugly interact
like how do you get these two spaghetti
is interacting like for example can you
have to spaghetti is coming and making a
bigger spaghetti out of it well maybe
that's how the things join together and
they split causes force between them
isn't that neat if you have some things
which are vibrating and coming and
coming together and then splitting up
causes of course say well that's the way
we think it's happening is there all the
particles are just least vibrating is
their spaghetti loops of some kind which
are actually interacting and giving all
possible forces around us isn't that
neat hopefully that when I saw influence
on their interests and the angel
question have you been able to finally
answer how long is a piece of string how
long is a piece of string so as I said
we think it's gonna be very tiny like 10
to the minus 30 centimeters so it's very
tiny so you have to put 10 to the 22 of
10 to 20 of them or more to get just one
add 10 to 20 years 10 billion 10 billion
so in billions of 10 billion of those
makes one atom you know how small that
one happens that's what we think is
roughly the scale of string but we don't
have a proof because we haven't seen
cool thank you very much thank you for
more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today to the Institute of Arts
and ideas at IAI TV
you